sea gx igual a 1 / x podemos usar el
teorema del valor intermedio para decir
que hay un valor ce tal que gdc es igual
a cero y menos 1 es menor o igual a c
que a su vez es menor o igual a 1 de ser
así escribe una justificación entonces
para poder usar el teorema del valor
intermedio la función tiene que ser
continua en el intervalo que nos
interesa y aquí el intervalo de x que
nos interesa va de menos 1 a 1 y la
función uno entre x no es continua en
ese intervalo y no está definida cuando
x es igual a cero así que podemos decir
que no porque gdx no está definida
o mejor vamos a decir que no es continua
aunque también no está definida en cada
uno de los puntos del intervalo pero
digamos que no es continuo en el
intervalo cerrado que va de menos uno a
uno entre paréntesis escribiré que no
está definido
no está definida en x igual a 0
bien ahora veamos la segunda pregunta
podemos usar el teorema del valor
intermedio para decir que la ecuación
que de x igual a tres cuartos tiene una
solución en donde uno es menor o igual a
equis que a su vez es menor o igual a 2
de ser así
escribe una justificación bueno primero
vamos a analizar el intervalo si
pensamos en el intervalo que va de 1 a 2
podemos ver que nuestra función será
continua en ese intervalo así que
podemos decir que g x es continua en el
intervalo cerrado que va de 1 a 2 y si
queremos escribir más en nuestra
justificación
podemos decir que ge de x está definida
para todos los números reales tal que x
no es igual a 0
entonces gtx está definida para todos
los números reales tal que x no es igual
a 0 y también podemos decir que las
funciones racionales como 1 / x son
continuas en todos los puntos de su
dominio así estamos estableciendo muy
bien que la función g de x es continua
en ese intervalo y ahora necesitamos
saber qué valores toma gdx en los
límites del intervalo vamos a ver que de
1 es igual a 1 entre 1 y g de 2 es igual
a 1 entre 2
por lo tanto 3 entre 4 está entre g1 y
g2 así que por el teorema del valor
intermedio teorema del valor intermedio
debe existir una equis que se encuentre
en el intervalo que va de 1 a 2
qué gx sea igual a tres cuartos entonces
la respuesta es que si podemos usar el
teorema del valor intermedio para decir
que la ecuación gdx igual a tres cuartos
tiene solución hemos terminado pero nos
vemos en otro vídeo